this talk is streams the data structure
we need or it can be shortened to OMG
streams feel free to use it as a hashtag
and I'm Pam celli you can find me on
twitter at Pam ass or my blog is the web
before com so the thesis of this talk
and it's a top for all levels so we'll
go from beginning to the end and so
streams are the most awesome data
structure that you don't know enough
about so first we'll talk about streams
it kind of contacts what they are
streams why you should be super excited
about them as a data structure and we'll
talk about because javascript is my jam
we'll talk about streams and how they're
expressed in JavaScript now and we'll
also talk about some libraries and
emerging standards because it's
JavaScript and so there's always
something new so that's the agenda for
the day so streams streams streams so
starting with some history so I when I
started getting really interested in
learning about streams of the data
structure I wanted to see where it came
from and it seems as far as I could tell
that streams first made their appearance
as a data structure in UNIX and so if
you don't think you know much about
streams there's a decent chance that
you've used streams as the data
structure just in your terminal on the
day to day so all glory to the pipe
operator so the pipe operator is that
skinny line in between these two
commands so cat being a command that
concatenates to the terminal and grep
being a global search and replace and so
in this we have a text file that's best
animals and we're going to search within
it for instances of cats
so best animals by itself and then let's
search case-insensitive for instances of
cat because the internet is run by cats
and we see that we use the pipe operator
to take the output from the first
command and send it to the second
command so that's what happened and
that's the the red lines the pipe
operator so but what our stream so
that's that's a oh you probably using
streams that even realizing it and
that's where they kind of come from
historically but what are they so
streams are an abstract data structure
meaning that when we talk about abstract
data structure abstract data structures
I sometimes have a hard time wrapping my
head around them because they have that
convenient word abstract in front of
them and so what that means is that we
might not in some cases we will but
we'll see streams expressed but they can
be expressed in many different ways and
because they're abstract so sometimes
that it might not even be called a
stream and sometimes it'll be call the
stream and there will be many different
implementations of it and you probably
you might even been to talks about
streams already here at strangely so
streams are not strict data structure
and I'm going to do a real-world demo
allah elementary school science class to
show you how streams work so over here I
have some cups so in going to go left to
right some my right your left so in the
first cup I have water and the ultimate
goal is that it has to get to this cup
but because reasons or business logic it
has to go through this middle cup in
between it has to it's the world so we
can do it this way and we do this kind
of operation all the time we take a
source and we transform it somehow we
put it somewhere and then we ultimately
output it however if you want to do it a
different way just shuffle these up
let's replace that middle cup with
something a little different
so that's pretty much how streams work
if you were to teach it in elementary
school science class in my humble
opinion and it's a fun way to think
about streams so instead of pouring from
one into the next and into the next and
doing things sequentially in that way we
send it through to the output so I'm
gonna reference as ICP a couple times in
the dock and just in case you haven't
heard of it structure interpretation of
computer programs is a generally a
textbook if you have a degree in
computer science you may have used it if
you have a greenside computer science
you haven't read it you probably feel
guilty about it and so what does sicp
this canonical text say about streams so
sicp says streams are delayed list okay
so what does that mean so Adelaide list
it means that we can treat them mostly
like a list structure but you don't have
you don't have to have all the values at
once so it's a data structure that lets
us do list operations without the
expense and annoyance of having to have
them in a list structure so they've
become really powerful so why would you
use them so they're really powerful but
why so because we can't or don't want to
hold everything in memory so we got to
avoid holding things in the middle cup
in our science experiment and bandwidth
is expensive these are facts that are
still true about the world they haven't
changed yet but meanwhile while
bandwidth is still expensive and we
don't want to store all the things in
memory streams are really great data
structure so streams and why you should
be super stoked about them so streams
let you represent possibly infinite data
infinite data making you essentially a
wizard and they're really really cool
and that's why I got really excited
about them as a data structure and I
wanted to write a talk about them so
what are some things that don't have an
end you say infinite
there's no such thing as infinite data
wrong we have natural numbers there's no
such thing as a terminal natural number
because anytime we have any number we
can always make a new natural number by
adding one to it so there's no such
thing as a final natural number whether
theoretically ends eventually user input
key strokes so in JavaScript role
especially in the client side we do with
this all the time large data sets and
your heartbeat these have stars next to
them because they definitely do have an
end but you just don't know what it is
so while you're you're collecting data
you operate on the assumption that you
don't you don't know when it ends and
streams let you do that so why I brought
up sicp is I don't really like using
quotes and talks but I just really
really like this so stream processing
lets us model systems that have state
without ever using assignment or mutable
data that is really awesome so let's do
it again so stream processing let you
have your state but you don't have to
use assignment or mutable data those
things that we aren't that into so you
can move faster you aren't storing
things in memory and we aren't mutating
data very popular topic or strange loop
so modes of stream so that's streams at
the very abstract sense but then you
actually have kind of two modes that you
can express streams and you can express
them in push and pull modes so what's a
push stream so push stream is like the
fire hose so it's I think the the fire
hydrant is a pretty apt image think of
it's just coming out and so and
especially in streams you'll see the
language expressed in multiple ways so
we have a producer a consumer we have a
source we have an observed and the
observer and we're using almost
different language and we're talking
about the same thing it's all streams
but because they're an abstract data
structure I think that's why we end up
using a lot different language so you
might be using a push stream if you see
things like callbacks so
when I have stuff from the source do
something with it they're non-blocking
so the fire hydrants just blasting stuff
at you or the fire hose is open and the
downside because everything has a
downside there's you know a downside to
any implementation is possible overload
so if you it's like if you opened a fire
hose on a tiny basil plant it wouldn't
handle it very well so thinking about
the context will change what kind of
stream implementation you would want to
use so a poll stream is the idea like
ideally the opposite in a way so instead
of the source or the producer pushing
all that so push stream pushing all that
data at you and the poll stream the
consumer is in charge of getting our
data so if you have a tiny basil plan
it's like it could wave is hand and say
like oh I need more water please and so
you might be using a poll stream if you
see things like iterators and they are
blocking and so I i love this from i
think i first heard it from jessica
Cara's talks that you'll have to timeout
because if you are blocking you need to
never ever block forever and so I think
of this I think of pull streams like
it's kind of like a lake and there's
like a lake of data and you have you a
bucket and you have a bucket and you can
walk the lake you can get your water
it's a lot of water themes here and so
you can walk back to your campsite or
what have you but while you're doing
that you can't do anything else like
you're carrying the bucket and back and
forth and you can take the bucket and do
your thing but then you have to walk
back and that takes time so it's
blocking so that's how pull streams
that's their trade off is that while you
have more control over when you get your
data you end up blocking so streams in
JavaScript so what do we have right now
in JavaScript
sonos dreams are conveniently named our
push streams so a node stream throws
data at the nest which makes a lot of
sense in the JavaScript conscience too
so the classic example so sub status
great stuff about streams and node and
so that's going to be in the reference
sheet but here is a simple example of a
a silly node server so it does does the
thing here's the important part so the
important part is so the FS file system
reads the file and then it reads it all
into memory and then it sends the data
to the response so that's one way to
ride a server lets you know this one way
another way is to write a server with a
readable stream and so here's the
important part the spacing is a little a
little different so that I could fit in
well but so the stream we create a
readable stream and then I love that
this is why we mentioned UNIX as well
earlier is it uses the pipe keyword so I
i do like no streams a lot I feel like
they fit the mental model of what a
stream data structure is really well for
me so we actually take the stream and we
pipe it to the response just like we
would in UNIX will not dress but yeah
you get the idea so we're piping rather
than using memory and so when we see
this in action on the server you can
make the server a lot faster you aren't
dark don't have to store things in that
second decimal second or n these'll so
go no streams are awesome I like them so
what else so in es6 or also known as
es2015 we have generators and so this is
a very new thing to javascript land so
it's available in other languages in
different forums but in javascript this
is how we have generators so generators
are reusable and possible functions if
you were to if if you're in javascript
in your having trouble getting
generators this is the thing this is
their reusable and possible functions so
that sounds familiar are they pull
streams
so because you asked for more when you
want more that's how a generator works
it's it it's an iterator it's blocking
it looks like all those things that we
talked about we talked about talked
about pull streams so when you use a
generator if you want to move to the
next value you you call next you say I'm
going to take the bucket again and go
get more more data so you know it's a
generator when this is how talking about
how they look in JavaScript so in
JavaScript that we have the function and
the star and then yield an if you see
these two bits you are working with a
generator so here's a simple example so
i Function something yields to ok great
so it's reusable so we can create an
instance of it and so we say s equals us
something so SI something and then we
say s next and then that will give us
back our two will get our yield so
generators demos so let's do this have
some some fun with generators so here's
a simple dinner let's see if it works
right away yeah so every time I click
the button that I'm going to iterate
through the generator so we'll look at
it happening and then we'll look at the
code that makes it happen so we're
console logging something something else
or something else entirely and the
generator is done and if I keep paying
the button it's still done it's read
once so reusable and possible functions
but they're read once like once you get
all the water out of the lake there's no
water water in the lake so that's a
simple generator so let's see what it
looks like over here so here's some
setup and so here just here at the top
of the elements and clicking and so
here's our remember we said okay we have
a function star and we have our yield so
that means we're working with a
generator and so when we go through it
when we first call it so next value is
what we're doing is time we click so we
we create a paragraph element and I'm
actually passing I'm yielding this so
that I can inspect the done value so
generator done is
so generate next done and so that's
actually calling the generator not next
there and appending it to the to the
document body so what's happening so
each time we call it so the first time
we call it we're getting to this yield
and so we yield this that's the first
time soon we saw a console log something
the next time we call it we console.log
something else and then we get to the
yield the third time we call it we have
no more yields but we have still a final
line in our generator and so that's when
that gets us computed which is a really
great use case for cleanup or a finally
or something like that that you might
want to do at the end of the consumption
of some data so now that we've looked at
it let's just run again just to kind of
embed that knowledge there we go should
have pushed that button down June right
something something else and something
else entirely and so that's the simple
and a minor Leela's trivial example
let's switch to to a different one so
just change the javascript file and then
we'll have a different generator running
when I should have pushed that button
down cheat to win all right here we go
all right so generate John went to the
store and said hey there to the clerk so
that's our different year so what's
actually happening so this still trivial
about mine early that's trivial
generator but an example of a reusable
and possible function so string breaker
because reasons it breaks up a string
and gives you back a word each time
unless there is a phrase or statement in
quotes it's very simple so the string
breaker Ezzat accumulator we look at 44
of which is actually also a cool es6
syntax thing that I'm really into you
were sad about four in now you have four
of be happy and so we have a we've kind
of a state machine of sorts running
through and so we yield and then we were
the end just to be good about it and so
here's at the end so where each time we
click were a pending a new word so John
went to the store and said hey there so
that's our in quotes to the clerk and
with the four of we could also do this
we can use for of what generators so not
only with you know with object literals
where everyone has done this where we
use for in and we end up with indexes
instead of values and it's terrible so
and we can iterate through the hole
generator and so we can just say I just
want everything from the generator so if
you have you can set up more complex
generators like this and say and just go
through all of it give me give me the
data from the generator so that's the
basics of JavaScript january's AKA pole
streams so can you use them I'm actually
doing these demos in in chrome with no
polyfills so yes but like everything in
JavaScript you probably need a polyfill
if you have to support you know other
people so Babel j/s is the transpiler
that is the upper operator of choice in
this space so step three libraries in
emerging standard so we saw some some
you know readable are some push trees
and some pull streams and JavaScript
that are today ish and we also have some
libraries and emerging standards that
are really exciting so some libraries
for working with streams so there's a
the three ones that I would say are the
major ones that I like a lot bacon
hyland an RX so bacon here's bacon j/s
with the scary parts taken out if you
didn't get that joke I crossed out
everything that said functional reactive
programming so bacon is great is a
really great entry point to doing stream
programming in JavaScript because it's
very jquery I believe it even uses the
dollar sign and so you get your list
operations on stream like objects such
as event dreams so like remember user
events clicks
covers any kind of browser event is a
series of it's a series of values that
we don't know when it went it ends so it
can be expressed as a stream highland
j/s I really like and this is kind of
the first one of these that i got into
is because i liked it as a stream
constructor so I like when the words
actually mapped to the computational
concepts and so the stream can sector
eight steps an array of values or a
generator function as an optional
argument so their constructor lets you
put in lots of different values so you
could use arrays generators node streams
jquery elements promises i actually
really like it for this reason i'm sure
that a lot of people don't like it for
this reason that is providing a common
interface for many different types so i
think that's really cool and then our
xjs quickly summarized as reactive tools
stream friendly batteries included if
you're a strange job you might be
familiar with the reactive x family and
our xjs is part of that family or and
there's a version being but right now
I'm briefly mentioned later so hold on
reactive programming this is the Trojan
horse in the JavaScript talk but no
we're all so strange dip so you aren't
surprised so this video helps a lot and
this was actually probably it might have
been my favorite talk a strange loop in
2014 Evans talk on the formulations of
frp and I've watched this multiple times
and in terms of being what understand
frp or RP conceptually I really think
it's absolutely fantastic also
recommended stouts has this entered our
x blog post this actually exists but
it's really good and so i highly
recommend reading that because if you're
if you're following along with this
you're probably having that realization
that in the world that we exist in now
like streams I'd say streams are like
the data structure like we exist in
massive amounts of data we exist in real
time data so data where we don't know
when it's going to end and data
structure for you for you and my friends
his dreams so his post really does a
good good job of getting you into that
mindset
so some emerging standards so again it's
JavaScript so of course someone's
writing some specifications on this so
let's see what we may be or may not get
so the thing that this is really cool so
there's actually a browser stream
standard so that we could actually get a
stream data type in the browser this is
a rough one because it's gonna involve
browser vendors it's not a standard
library kind of thing it's a browsers
have to be able to support it but if and
when it happens it's going to be really
awesome and among the many people
working on it there are people from the
node team who are involved in this spec
and of course you can always check the
specs and they're being updated
constantly fetch API the stream spec is
really like also that you should get
really excited about this one so the
fetch API is going to prevent you from
ever having to write xml httprequest
ever again or pulling in jquery so you
don't have to so the fetch API provides
that interface that everyone has pretty
commonly adapted the dollar Ajax style
and makes it into a native API and of
course there's polyfills for this and so
you can you can use it now if you're
willing to add a playful but the really
cool thing about the fetch API is that
not only is it providing that kind of
dollar today Jax's you know get the
stuff and then but that's kind of like
that's like the the silly the first node
server we looked at in the future when
we have the browser streams it's going
to look like that second node server and
this is really really cool so when we
because I mean how many times have you
had that you you get your data and then
you have to you know deal with it being
JSON of course so we get response that
JSON when that is streams you should my
dream is that you will be able to do
things like massive data visualizations
like that's the thing that I'm most
excited about and that's like the
beginning you know that's just the most
obvious thing to me which means that
people are going to do really cool
things so that if massive data
visualizations is the first thing I
thought of but being able to handle data
without pagination big deal being able
to and I'm just so excited about that
visualization opportunities in this
object out observe so you might have
seen some talks about this it's I if I
were to you know bet on a standard i
think i might bet on this one as
something that's probably going to
happen yes seven aka es 2016 so not now
eventually but object out observe so
given an object or object things which
in javascript is most everything we can
observe it and then react to changes so
does that sounds familiar right that
sounds like a push stream so it's a
series of events and we react when it
changes we're consuming the data as we
get it the observable type really cool
one and so this is what we see in the RX
j s library so this existing library
that people being using for a while is
also it the main you know stuff of it is
an observable type and that's actually
proposed to be added to the standard
library next year so proposal for es
seven so we can create an observable of
values or events and then we can do list
operations on them remember list
operations without the annoyance and
expensive lists so some small projects
using some of these tools so we talked
about history we talked about javascript
today we talked about emerging things
and I've got some examples of me
actually doing stuff with these so that
you can actually see them in action so
the last week blog so tell me what's new
from the last week on my blogs so this
so much reveal example so watch the
screen if I'm who am I on the Wi-Fi will
see otherwise everything else is already
offline so but this one depends on
hitting the network
did you see that do you see it didn't it
didn't render like a usual browser page
so what's actually happening in the last
week blog is fetching all these there's
a yam will file in the project that has
names and indexes or names and locations
of different blogs so that I could check
and see hey like Arthur you know have my
friends written anything in the last
week I put New York Times up there
because sadly my friends aren't super
prolific on their blogs but so you can
see it actually went like this it didn't
it you didn't kind of get a kind of
standard browser flash and so that's why
should happen in last week blog as its
it uses Highland to do this and of
course the sources on my github it's
very trivial but hopefully that makes it
more accessible to see what's going on
but so we go and get all the source of
the blog's we get their RSS transform it
filter it lists operations and then we
pipe that response to the browser as we
get it so we don't have to wait for you
know because as cool as processing RSS
feeds is we don't have to store all that
in memory we just we deal with it and
we're done with it and then we get our
answer so that is last week blog so the
space-time app uses the fascia API sadly
of course it doesn't we don't have
browser streams but it does use the
fetch API so what's the space-time app
so this is a data visualization so
there's a DeLorean and there's the plane
of stars and so you can drive your
DeLorean you can see how the stars move
over time you drive your de loin forward
and backward we've all seen the movies
right so so we've got it's really cool
because if you think about you know
honest i think i remember is correct
like plus or minus one hundred thousand
years um but at that point like
relativity comes into play but it's
pretty cool to think about how like our
stars didn't look the same as you know a
thousand years ago based on our place in
space anyway so this uses a lot of data
so
what actually looks like when it's using
the fetch API is it it fetches the
stupid number of stars and returns and
then does stuff with the Stars and with
them we you know do all this cool 3jf
stuff to make a plane of stars and
represent them in a visualization also
bonus and of course if you're a
JavaScript ER you might have heard of
you know every single build system but
one of them is gold and why gulp is bill
system big fan is that it relies on
streams so we do things and we actually
have a pipe operator so I really love
when the when the language maps to the
mental model I feel like it makes it
really sticky and so that's the one that
like that's why when you switch from
another build systems front to go you
might see huge gains and speed because
instead of storing things and then doing
things with them your piping the values
you do sometimes get race conditions but
like that's going to happen and you can
deal with it I didn't deal with it very
well here but other people who can so
fix missing all flows ok so Millennials
to snake people so this uses object
observe to observe mutations to the DOM
and appropriately update uses of the
word millennial so this was first
written by Eric Bailey for chrome and I
added the Firefox extension and so you
get something like this which makes
reading the news a lot better um this
paragraph is probably my favorite so
replacing lots of vocabulary associated
with Millennials with appropriate snake
related puns so the code using observe
so it's you know and it's it's a
disturbingly simple it's so great so we
went so walk the document and replace
things and then set up your observers we
even replace the title of the document
so watch mutation
so watch when things changes change it
Washington things change and hit our
callback spoiler that callback replaces
mentions of the word millennial or you
know my favorite is that millennial
children become snake 'let's um but yeah
all credit to eric i ported it to
firefox but yeah I was it's a very fun
funny idea so and that's using streams
so we're using object at observe to
react and update things so servile
here's this is a bit of a trivial
example using our xjs I call it art this
is silly art with our xjs hello click to
move the circle so let's open the
console as well so moving circle around
and I'm getting my coordinates back so I
could do other interesting things but my
art is very simple you know I like it
that way sometimes but so in RX j acid i
just created an observable and we're
just we're watching clicks and we're
reacting to them i can do it pretty fast
too that's fast as a QA tester but you
know um no it's perfect so some
interesting links so some interesting
links that we have our node streams so
conveniently there's a website called
node streams com how great so and I did
I reference sub stack and the stream
handbook and stream adventure so stream
adventure is within the node school
library if you have not seen that it's a
command line interface game to learn
node and stream adventures one of them
so you can learn about streams in node
some generators I really like so get a
Phi on the Internet is Kyle Simpson and
he has this rat or example that he
posted that I really like because it's
you know especially when we get a new
thing it's hard to like when I talk
about the fetch API like or I think of
kind of the most obvious thing but then
we got it we got to be more creative
like once we have a new field we should
try and do weird and interesting things
or you know useful that's good too so
the round is useful so the routers of
showing that hey but don't we tend to
make routers a lot what if we made or
visible router and so that's a generator
and in his book you don't know Jas
there's the async and performance
generators chapter really like it and
Axl Rossmeyer has fantastic resources on
impending JavaScript standards all the
time but especially on this post on
generation deaf and the these slides are
on the internet and so you can go and
get all the links straight from them so
those reactive programming libraries
bacon Highland and RX and a few other
reactive things that are cool so our xjs
is is cool it's got batteries included
however it's not super usable like when
you're coming to it as a new person and
it definitely has some performance gains
to be made and so what's happening right
now is our X is being rjs is being
rewritten underneath another umbrella
and all that is happening in the wild
the alpha is out so you can go and you
can contribute to it I especially would
love to see more people contributing
docs because I'm I'm doing that a bit
and it's always good like you know fresh
set of eyes are some of the most
invaluable things on emerging projects
before they get too far down a bad path
and also created by stouts are the RX
marbles which if you're if you're new or
to some of those lists operations or
operating on those lists list of
functions on streams the arcs baubles
are really cool way to visualize it by
stalls who wrote that intro to our ex
post and if you said to yourself all
those libraries sound great Pam but I
really needed a JavaScript framework you
can use cycle Jas and so this is a
framework that is based on our xjs and
creates uses reactive programming as a
first class citizen in the JavaScript
framework so it's pretty new I'm
interested to see him where it's going
but it's def like something if you're
interested in this you'll want to check
out so the slides are at fusillade
github do OMG streams I'll tweet out and
thank you very much I I you can find me
for questions mingling around I'll do
that I also so Twitter pama sore
website at the web for also have a
podcast called Turing and complete and
if you like the joke you'll like the
podcast and we have stickers so if you
want some stickers or questions to talk
to me about talk to me after talks so
thank you so much